hello my name is jihad for Julie I'm a
global changemaker from Morocco today is
the last day of the World Economic Forum
and after attending the sessions I I can
feel that the you know after discussing
the problems with job creation in
unemployment in the in the MENA region
it's all boils down to changing the
mindset we for a long time we've been
caught up in a in a mindset of being
secure getting a government job you know
taking it really you know just being on
the safe side but I think that at this
moment where we're really trying to
shift this mindset into a mindset of
entrepreneurship mindset of taking risks
a mindset of seeing problems as
opportunities as opposed to problems and
this will take a lot of our efforts a
lot of our investments into education
into training and we have to have to try
and inspire youth in and get them to
believe in this idea of entrepreneurship
and get them to believe that they can be
entrepreneurs themselves and this even
though we need also you know we need
other with the government you need other
stakeholders to also do their part but
it's all boils down to inspiring the
youth in changing this mindset thank you